good morning John I'm on my way to the
western Montana blood bank I am own
negative Universal donor I'm like a
total blood stud they can't get enough
of this and I figured that this would be
an excellent opportunity to talk a
little bit about the human circulatory
system so at first I didn't know how to
start this video because there's no
beginning nor end to the human
circulatory system except for birth and
death and if you died then this really
is an interesting concept anymore
because you're dead or I guess you could
be a zombie
if you're a zombie I don't think it
would be interesting to you either so I
decided to do it from a perspective
where there is a beginning and an end
the life of a red blood cell now we're
gonna be talking about one red blood
cell and this one red blood cells name
is going to be RB we're calling him RB
not because he was created from the meat
of a roast beef sandwich so because back
in my biochem days we called red blood
cells RBC's and I'm just shortened in
that to RB and RB is one of the
trillions of red blood cells that you
have swimming around in your veins right
now delivering oxygen to all the places
that need oxygen
this aside from attracting the lust of
vampires is all that red blood cells do
and if they stop doing it you would die
instantly so be grateful I don't know
why it creeps me out that the blood bank
is in the old Creamery building but it
kind of does so the process of creating
a blood cell is called erythropoiesis
blood cells being erythrocytes and
poesis from the latin to make which
somewhat beautifully is also the root of
the word poetry the weirdest thing about
RB is that near the end of his creation
his nucleus not nuke ulis and all of his
organelles were kicked out of the cell
so by the time RV lost his nucleus he
had 270 million molecules of hemoglobin
I know this because I counted hemoglobin
is a marvelous protein complex that has
four molecules of heme attached to it
heme is an organic compound with an iron
Center the iron of course is there to
bond to oxygen and it is very very good
at bonding to oxygen if bombing the
oxygen was punk rock hemoglobin would be
the clash if it was soccer hemoglobin
would be Cristiano Ronaldo if it was
being delicious hemoglobin would be
corndogs
hemoglobin also only binds to oxygen
actually and unfortunately and someone
accidentally hemoglobin actually prefers
to bind a carbon monoxide which is why
when you breathe in too much carbon
monoxide you die but arby's hemoglobin
has never been exposed to oxygen much
less carbon monoxide so he has to go on
a little adventure
assuming that RV was created and say
your femur he now moves up the inferior
vena cava which happens to be the
largest vein in your body and into your
right atrium the right ventricle expands
sucking
the blood into it and then contracts
pumping the blood cell through the
pulmonary arteries pulmonary is the word
for anything having to do with the lungs
now it's important here to note arteries
carry blood away from the heart and
veins carry blood to the heart usually
things have deoxygenated blood in them
and arteries have oxygenated blood but
in the pulmonary artery blood is being
pumped away from the heart and toward
the lungs but there's actually
deoxygenated blood in them because they
haven't gotten to the lungs yet it seems
a little weird at first but it's not
it's not weird at all anyway our B heads
to your lungs where it goes into smaller
and smaller blood vessels until the
blood vessels are in fact smaller than
the diameter of the blood cell itself
these are called capillaries and in this
case they're on the inside of little
sacs called alveoli our sacs that
contain the air that you just breathe in
so as our v is squeezing through a
capillary a few things happen first we
realize why he kicked out his nucleus in
all of his organelles because if he
still had all that stuff he'd be way too
chubby to fit through a capillary
without the nucleus our V can be
gorgeous with 230 million molecules of
hemoglobin and still folded all sorts of
crazy shapes to fit through even the
smallest blood vessels but more
importantly because the hemoglobin
doesn't have any oxygen attached to it
and because there's tons of oxygen in
the alveolar sacs oxygen from the air
moves down its concentration gradient
and into the capillary and then into our
B where his hemoglobin sucks it all up
and because the hemoglobin keeps sucking
up all the oxygen the o2 concentration
remains low in the blood and it keeps
flowing in from the air and this
continues until the hemoglobin has
sucked up all of the oxygen it can the
now oxygenated RB heads back into the
heart through the pulmonary vein it's a
vein remember because it's headed to the
heart and the enters the left atrium
gets sucked into the left ventricle and
then flew out into the body where he
goes you know somewhere in the body
amazing thing about hemoglobin it knows
exactly when to dump all of its oxygen
and how does this is fascinating
okay so RB is full of an enzyme called
carbonic anhydrase and carbonic
anhydrase converts carbon dioxide and
water into carbonic acid h2co3 h2 co3 is
an acid meaning it dissociates into H+
and hco3 - and if you down your
chemistry homework you know what's going
on here that means the contents of RB
are getting more and more acidic
hemoglobin actually react with these
protons the H+ the things that are
making these things are sick and as it
does that it starts to
suck at holding on to oxygen now this
makes sense because the product of any
work being done by your body is carbon
dioxide and wherever co2 is created
there is a need for Oh - so wherever co2
concentrations are high your body needs
the o2 and arby's hemoglobin is dumping
it like crazy am i a huge dork for
thinking that that's beautiful and
elegant maybe but it is so now Harvey is
squeezing his way through the capillary
and dumping all of his o2 into tissues
that need it and we're pretty much back
where we started and all that's left is
for our V to do it again every 20
seconds for the next hundred or so days
before he's filtered out by your liver
and yes helps to make your poop brown
and that is really the only way that a
red blood cell will ever leave your body
unless you're bleeding which I hope you
want or giving blood which I hope you
are John I'll see you on Monday
okay I just gave blood and then I said
are be like 25 times so now I really
really really want a real speed sandwich
but I'm not going to go get one because
Arby's is so good so everyone down in
the pants area here tell me when the
last time you gave blood was and what
did you think I hadn't done it in a long
time and I thought that it was really
really easy give blood
it saves lots